I get the excitement because it's it's a
holiday crowd it's it's Groundhog Day
but it is this crowd know a guy and you
know this year because the groundhog is
browned and it gets pulled from its home
ice is involved so but forget Groundhog
Day the only large rat-like creature I'm
concerned about is Devon Nunez this guy
[Music]
today of course it's not fair to single
him out all the Republicans these days
are treasonous rats you know they're all
together they're on a retreat in West
Virginia and the people of that town are
onto them because the banner said
welcome banana Republicans which is what
we're turning into I mean this this
slow-moving code that I've been talking
about since before the election you know
kind of picked up speed this week Trump
Declassified this new news memo which is
supposed to make us think that our own
top law enforcement people are crooked
so Trump can get away with his rush of
crimes problem is the Republicans talked
about this memo you know like it's some
smoking gun piece of evidence that they
uncovered no they wrote it
[Applause]
they uncovered it in their printer it
excited intelligence document it's a
Facebook post that you'd briefly skim
before clicking unfriend but you know
the Republican they did not like what
the FBI was finding out about Trump so
like the true Patriots they are of
Russia they attacked the FBI and the
Justice Department because they're
biased yes because they're in law
enforcement and the crump Trump crime
family commits crimes so that's what
they're supposed to do it's like saying
the exterminator is biased against the
termites
[Applause]
paced myself I know I get pissed off too
early but right but don't you I mean
this Republican delusion that robert
muller a republican who's there because
of trump is conspiring with rod
Rosenstein the acting Attorney General a
Republican who's there because of Trump
and of course miller's old buddy Jim
Comey another Republican appointed by
Trump and and Trump's attitude is geez
what a bunch of what a bunch of idiots
who put them in jar
[Music]
but okay smearing the FBI and the
Justice Department is not the only thing
that fat Nixon was up to this week
[Applause]
it was also state-of-the-union time here
in America the dress the address was
delivered by trump's alter ego
teleprompter Trump I'm not going to say
the President of the United States can't
read but it's obvious he doesn't get a
lot of practice at it not great at the
teleprompter first of all during
rehearsals he kept referring to it as
Sri and he read it so slow he looked
like a guy taking an eye exam at one
point stormy Daniels pretended to come
just to make him stop
[Applause]
what you know but did you watch this
Beach he mentioned all the floods you
know the the wildfires the storms we've
had never once linked them to climate
change yes probably the work of the deep
state wouldn't you imagine
I need rag dove course about you know
the biggest tax cuts in history no like
the eighth biggest for finally seeing
wages going up they've been going up for
years car companies are building again
and expanding now that's been going on
for years where's the guy in the State
of the Union who else you live when you
need them
[Music]
[Applause]
as which with all state of the unions
you know that was the the gallery you
know they have the people up in the
gallery what they call the stunt casting
they do they've the people who tug at
your heartstrings and there were I mean
there were parents of victims of the
ms-13 crime gang and there was a blind
double amputee marine and then there was
one that I must say really got to me
there was a woman in the gallery who has
been forced to be married to Donald
Trump did you see Melania she was all
decked out all white outfit from Dior
Dolce and Gabbana blouse Louboutin heels
and a shock collar in case she made a
run for it and if you have any doubts
that Melania is very pissed and
humiliated by the strawberry Daniels
thing she broke all president did not
travel to the speech to the Capitol with
the president she came separately as
usual